el bolso de un niño ya se ha abandonado
en un aula después de que esta escuela
en el noroeste de nigeria fuera asaltada
por más de un centenar de hombres
armados a últimas horas del viernes
algunos estudiantes lograron escapar
cuando los asaltantes se enfrentaron en
una feroz batalla con las fuerzas de
seguridad pero cientos de los chicos
siguen desaparecidos y se cree que han
sido secuestrados no sabemos el número
exacto de estudiantes que han sido
secuestrados porque es posible que
algunos de los niños escaparon a los
bosques o se las arreglaron para llegar
a casa oa otro lugar donde te rogamos a
este gobierno por el amor de dios que
intensifique sus esfuerzos para que
nuestros hijos vuelvan a casa me negaron
entera
los secuestros fueron inicialmente
atribuidos a grupos armados conocidos
localmente como bandidos que llevan a
cabo secuestros a cambio de rescates el
gobierno dice que ahora está en contacto
con los atacantes y está negociando la
liberación de los niños este martes el
grupo yihadista boko haram se atribuyó
la responsabilidad del hecho pero sin
dar ningún detalle se cree que boko
haram solo tiene una presencia menor en
la región y no suele negociar con las
autoridades el primer gran ataque de los
yihadistas fue en sivok hace seis años
cuando 276 niñas fueron secuestradas por
el grupo terrorista docenas de ellas
siguen desaparecidas a principios de
este mes boko haram admitió haber matado
a decenas de cultivadores de arroz en el
norte de nigeria